but you know before my throat my
Christmas wants yeah Steve gave me a
pocket [ __ ] ooh for Christmas
flashlight now a pocket [ __ ] like an
old-school one right but it was the one
that I gave him ten years earlier he
gifted you again ten years ago yeah I
gave him a pocket [ __ ]
ten years ago what twelve years ago now
and then two years ago he tried to give
it back to me used like it was sticky
and it one of the lips were gone
and there was a couple of holes for some
reason like dog bite marks on it oh and
I'm like I didn't I buy is like oh yeah
I forgot I'll take it back it's the
thought that you would even think that
that would be a Christmas gift that you
wouldn't go out and do it like a normal
person and go buy me like a Starbucks
gift card or something you know what I'm
gonna use that he's rapping he writes in
a car yeah and then you throw away
whatever he gives you well I just don't
like [ __ ] gifts like no he got you
socks those are fine but your [ __ ]
gift [ __ ] [ __ ] don't like it
okay you have to like it if it wasn't
Bush I want something nice Oh what is
nice iPad hey Gilbert whose big 20
national commercials Gibby guy attacked
what one day when you make money I went
oh oh I'll get you nice and I'll get you
nice gift when I'm a hero or something
that can use I'll be something good you
ever stop with this bullshit's like
rocks or first of all don't accuse me of
giving you rocks I know but I mean her
friend Jessica gave me a pillow what is
he was enough pillow it was it was kind
of this little hug thing you could put
your iPad up doesn't work it's pointless
Naoko you could just do this yeah but
your little arm do you look t-rex arms
don't burn that's not what you calling a
t-rex arm you hayden Panettiere arms
have you seen a little chunky right now
he has the biggest you ever been no yes
really
oh yeah he's five four three and a
hundred seventy five you do them that's
as small as you've been
five years ago I weighed about 140 oh
yeah I was going to the gym when I first
went to the jail go every night and
you're on steroids
you've revealed that Oh sis yo I think I
found some is in the red container it
was there was a syringe and everything
and I thought to myself oh my god what I
did through why are you gonna use it
what if I want to get buff again baby
what think Kevin Randleman Kimbo Slice
yeah everybody who's ever died Kevin
Randleman kill site this is star Chris
Benoit kick haven't read let's write
what do they have similarities those two
don't like it but you say what are the
similarities between the two providers
their fighters was a lawyer I go I rest
my case
yeah yeah yeah enough said what about
like Eddie Guerrero or Chris Benoit I
don't know them they're wrestlers
they're WWE God no they went into you
know Chris Benoit ended up killing his
whole family shooting him on a roid rage
that's what they say in the media no
babe all these guys because they in the
90s roids were basically equal to gold
everybody did roids in the night every
UFC fighter you've ever even heard of
Don Frye [ __ ] Ken Shamrock Tito Ortiz
all those guys did Royce we asked you a
question
yeah is Don Frye Tito Ortiz or Coleman
dead
no I rest my case
he's keep saying I rest my case I leave
the courtroom and I just rip up paper as
confetti and I just walk out of the
courtroom as you guys there yeah yeah
all right you're at this pointless what
you're saying okay but I'm glad you
throw them away because I don't you know
it makes me really angry yeah I get
raped like you don't that I go into a
ring more than Destiny rage oh no you
have no I didn't know what sir what my
story rage is like punching holes in the
wall Jesus man yeah dude roid rage is a
[ __ ] man I had a I knew a guy in when I
used to live in Las Vegas and he was one
of the nicest guys you could ever meet
just super sweet he ended up beating his
girlfriend outside of a block bus
where she worked like this way back in
the day he dragged her by her hair out
she was working in a blockbuster dragged
her by her hair during her lunch during
his lunch break and just started beating
the [ __ ] out of her to a bloody pulp and
he was a nicest guy ever and he was just
roid raging not a nice guy you know but
that maybe since you thought that she
needed a better job why would you work
or even there was a there's a guy on The
Bachelorette this season's bachelor she
was so obviously roided his name's chad
gusting ly douchey